histoire c'est à propos d'un jeune cavalier américain
qui tombe amoureux d'un homme britannique est-ce que son
fils est
plutôt bien mort pensez-vous vraiment et
cramoisi chaque personnage se bat
pour l'amour serais-tu à moi
cramoisi pic est l'histoire de qui
gagne qui peut vivre
qui  arrive à aimer Edith c'est ma sœur
Lady Lucille Shaw la seule personne qu'elle
aime au monde est son frère
quand ils étaient orphelins ils n'avaient que l'un
l'autre tu dois me faire confiance quand
quelqu'un d'autre entre dans une dynamique comme
ça ça remue définitivement les choses
Je suis des pikas à propos de deux façons différentes
d'aimer mais il y a une obscurité et un
égoïsme
avec ce
que parfois les gens font par amour, c'est
ce que ces films sur l'amour font des
monstres d'une âme
vous